foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
hearts of Westminster
prime minister might be feeling pretty
happy with himself he's got a brexit
deal over the line with the EU and so
far it's had a decent reception although
we're still waiting for the
all-important verdict of the dep and
that means some breathing space for
Rishi sunak while attention turns to an
MP who's never been far from the
spotlight in recent years Matt Hancock
after he handed over a hundred thousand
of his pandemic whatsapps to a
journalist he was surprised when they
ended up on the front page of a
newspaper meanwhile teachers across
England strike tomorrow and an important
Sky News investigation came up in the
Commons today lots for us to get stuck
into as we bring you takes from all
sides over the next 60 minutes
Farmers across the country will look at
this and the site of politicians writing
books portraying themselves as heroes or
selectively leaking messages will be
insulting and ghoulish spectacle for
them
Matt Hancock has insisted he did nothing
wrong he says the telegraph report was
one-sided and the PM said that everyone
should wait for the official inquiry
into the pandemic
rather than comment on piecemeal bits of
information I'm sure the honorable
General agree with me the right way for
these things to be looked at is the
covert inquiry that's why we've
established the covert inquiry and he
will know he will know as I have he has
mentioned it one or two times before
that he was a lawyer in a previous life
that there is a proper process to these
things
now there was plenty more in pmqs
including that deal over Northern
Ireland we'll have more on that in this
hour as well and we've got some top
guests for you too including the schools
Minister Nick Gibb ahead of those
teacher strikes uh next to that tomorrow
the chair at the labor party as well
Annelise dawds will be on the program
too and we'll speak to the labor and P
Rosie Duffield much more besides on the
take
[Music]
thank you
hello good evening thanks very much for
joining us let's start shall we with
that route over Matt Hancock it's all
about whether he ignored advice from
senior scientists during the pandemic
said anyone going into a care home
should be tested for kovid now the
former house secretary says it's
outrageous that a distorted account of
the pandemic is being pushed well let's
try and get to the bottom of All Shall
We with our science editor Tom Clark
on the 14th of April 2020 Matt Hancock
was on his way to the Daily covid Press
briefing but according to WhatsApp
messages published by The Daily
Telegraph the same day he was also
messaging civil servants about an urgent
recommendation
from chief medical officer Chris Whitty
that all people being admitted to Care
Homes should be tested for covid at this
point in the pandemic both men knew how
grave the situation in Care Homes was
deaths from the first wave of covert had
hit their Peak on the 10th of April the
vast majority of them nearly 20 000 in
that wave were care home residents
yet it appears when the whatsapp's
published that Mr Hancock rejected the
cmo's advice replying he'd rather leave
out Community testing adding it muddies
the waters the former Health secretary
has now hit back a spokesperson saying
key elements of the messages had been
omitted which showed he'd supported sir
Chris whitty's advice his former
colleague the social care Minister said
something similar to The Commons earlier
I should mention that selective Snippets
of WhatsApp conversations give a limited
and at times misleading insight into the
Machinery of government at the time Mr
Hancock said the reason for not
following the cmo's advice was that
there wasn't sufficient covid testing
capacity available at the time of the
WhatsApp exchange there was only
capacity for around 70 000 tests a week
but within two weeks it was about to
grow exponentially something those
involved at the time say ministers would
have been very aware of I would find it
impossible for someone seeing it at dhsc
to suggest that they weren't the
position to know
it was going to be a significant change
in PCR testing capacity in the next two
weeks at that time
messages published by the telegraph
employment to Hancock's reluctance to
scale up Community testing was due to
his desperation to hit his Target of a
hundred thousand covid tests a day by
the end of April I am now setting the
goal of 100
000 tests per day by the end of this
month
that is the goal and I am determined
that we will get that as the deadline
loomed he messaged then evening standard
editor George Osborne declaring I want
to hit my target
are the messages evidence of a health
secretary being Guided by politics not
the science or tidbits Cherry Picked by
journalists with their own agenda well
that's one reason we have inquiries in
response to the revelations the UK
covert inquiry said evidence like
WhatsApp messages has been requested
from all key Witnesses
if one former minister's phone archive
contains explosive details there are
many many more to come Tom Clark Sky
News
well Matt Hancock has released a
statement in response to the allegations
in which he says having not been
approached and advanced by the telegraph
we have reviewed the messages overnight
the telegraph intentionally excluded
reference to a meeting with a testing
team from the WhatsApp this is critical
because Matt was supportive of Chris
Whitey's advice held a meeting on its
deliverability told it wasn't
deliverable and insisted on testing all
those who came from hospitals the
telegraph had been informed that their
headline is wrong and Matt is
considering all the options available to
him this major era by Isabel Oak shorts
and the telegraph shows why the proper
place for analysis like this is an
inquiry not a partial agenda-driven leak
of confidential documents
the response from Matt Hancock now let
do what we always do on the show shall
we and bring you the week in politics so
far because it really has been dominated
by one big political story in town which
is your next deal with the EU over
Northern Ireland let's take a look
today's agreement
delivers smooth flowing trade within the
whole United Kingdom
protects Northern Ireland's place in our
Union
and safeguards sovereignty for the
people of Northern Ireland the New
Windsor framework is here to benefit
people in Northern Ireland the king
meeting Ursula Wonderland a pair of met
on several occasions before but meeting
on a day like today after A Moment Like
This Afternoon does put the king very
close to a deeply uh divisive and
controversial political issue arishi
sunak's been in Northern Ireland today
to sell his new brexit deal he said he
thinks she's done enough to address the
concerns of unionists as my right
honorable friend agree with me
that the best move now is for everybody
across this house to support this
settlement because that is what is in
the best interests of all the people of
Northern Ireland we need to examine very
carefully what the legal text means how
will these measures be implemented in
practice after weeks of negotiations
today we have made a decisive
breakthrough The Windsor framework
delivers free-flowing trade within the
whole United Kingdom in clear for some
time
that if the Prime Minister were to get
an agreement with the EU and if their
agreement is in the interests of this
country and Northern Ireland
then labor would support it respect of
the inevitable issue which is about to
be mentioned and that is domestic treaty
because she was the speaker which I had
to deal with
absolutely incredible things there did
you see that Theresa May pretending to
fall asleep I think
as one of her members of uh her own
benches started talking about uh brexit
we've had a lot about brexit this week
we've had a lot of course about Matt
Hancock but I know that there is one
story that lots of you are going to be
more concerned about than any others and
that is that lots of schools closing
tomorrow because of strike action by
teachers a little earlier I spoke to the
schools Minister Nick Gibb we did talk
about Matt Hancock 2 and the deal over
Northern Ireland but I started with
those School strikes in England starting
tomorrow
strikes tomorrow how many schools are
shutting well we expect based on our you
know intelligence we've had that most
schools will be either fully open or or
open with restrictive access it's
broadly similar to what happened on the
first of February but it's going to
impact lots of parents and teachers at
the same time right yes it is and it's
unnecessary because you know we wrote to
the NAU and the Royal College of Nursing
last week as a government offering very
serious discussions and negotiations on
pay on workload all the issues that are
of concern to teachers and are of
concern to nurses on condition that they
paused this week's strikes and the
nurses were happy to do that and they
and right now the nursing Union the RCN
are in discussions with the government
about pay and all those other issues
that are important to nurses but the Neu
for their own I think internal reasons
within the NAU itself said they couldn't
pause the strikes and so we haven't
we're not negotiating the only won't
pause the strikes because they don't
trust you right I spoke to Mary balstead
the head of the NAU at the weekend she
said that the talk so far have been in
her words silly no we've been having
very good discussion since
we'll be talking about issues like pay
we'll be discussing the evidence that
we're submitted to the pay review body
we've been talking about workload one of
the issues that does concern teachers is
workload we've been talking about
Recruitment and Retention in those
discussions but but now we've offered
them very serious discussions actually
about the pay for 2022 and for 2023-24
and uh we couldn't have been more clear
that those discussions were serious and
we had things to talk about but because
they can't get their executive to agree
to apportion the strikes that's why
these strikes have gone ahead this way
if you want to stop the strikes right
and you want kids back in school
children who've missed so much because
of covert already why do you need the
precondition why don't you just say look
here's our offer are you really straight
with them say look we'll go up to this
amount well first of all we can't
negotiate those figures in the in the in
the media light so we need to have those
discussions behind closed doors as the
nurses are but secondly we need to know
that they are serious we have been very
clear that we are serious but they've
got to indicate that they are serious
and one way of indicating that is to
pause the strike but why why why does
that matter because we need to know that
the the issue that stopped them pausing
the strikes is their own internal
politics now we need to know that their
own internal parties isn't going to
prevent us from coming to an agreement
in those negotiations we want serious
discussions uh with no Bowsers with
Kevin Courtney the leader of the joint
General secretaries of the National
Education Union and all the other unions
as well we need to know that we're going
to have a serious set of discussions
talking about that I mean one of the
ways that you could do that is to give
them a bit of indication that you are
willing to compromise when it comes to
pay the ifs The Institute for fiscal
study is saying that salaries for
teachers on most pay grades expected to
fall by five percent in real terms and
even inexperienced teachers who will see
a larger pay rise real terms cuts of one
to three percent well we gave a five
percent the the pay review body uh
recommended a five percent pay increase
for 2022 which we accepted eight point
nine percent for newly qualified
teachers again we accepted that that's
leading to thirty thousand pounds
starting and you're willing to go up on
that now well that's 2022 we will talk
about 2022 we've said we'll talk about
those in in our negotiations 2023 we've
submitted the evidence to the
independent school teachers peer review
body and and that that is the
affordability and also don't forget we
have in the Autumn statement so if we
increase spending on schools by 2
billion pounds on in addition to what
was already agreed so if you take next
year the three and a half billion pound
increase this year's four billion pound
increase in school funding that's a 15
increase over those two years in school
funding so you're willing to go up on
the five percent payoff that's what
you're effectively saying right now what
I'm saying is we're not discussing uh
the details of the negotiations through
the media we've got to have those
discussions with the four unions behind
closed doors away from the immediate
Spotlight can you and I just I just
think sometimes if your parent listen to
this you might be just thinking oh my
goodness because you know you're saying
look we're not going to talk pay in the
media they're saying look we're not
going to talk unless you show us that
you're serious about it you're saying
we're not going to talk to you unless
you call off the strikes and the parents
are sitting here thinking just come on
just why don't you just tell them what
you're prepared to work what we have
said is that we will talk about 2020 23
and we will talk about 23 24. we'll talk
about the workload that teachers face
the you know the unnecessary tasks that
they seem to have to do we want that to
sweep that away we'll talk about
Recruitment and Retention so we've we've
said that explicitly we've written to
the unions explicitly we wrote to the
Royal College of Nursing on the same
lines and they have said yes they will
conduct those negotiations we want to
get on with them what we can't have is
pay negotiations being done through
strike action jeopardizing young
people's life chances by taking more
days out of school as you say they've
had two years of disruption during the
covid pandemic and we don't want and
we're spending 5 billion pounds helping
students to catch up from that pandemic
what we don't need is is children losing
more days of their education uh
it's something that you said in February
in an interview let's just have a quick
listen to this
now I do want that to be the secretary
Secretary of State wants there to be a
properly rewarded and motivated teaching
profession because this is one of the
most important professions in our
country I want to see standards in our
schools continue to rise as they have
been and you need a proper teaching
profession well rewarded well motivated
in our schools to deliver that I mean
you see that right you're talking about
a retention of teachers you're talking
about a teaching body that you think
needs to be properly rewarded you
mentioned you know the billions of extra
money are given to schools in the Autumn
do you think that should be spent on
teacher salaries if that's the most
important thing
well what we said in the evidence to
this the pay review body is that the
affordability is about three and a half
percent pay increase for teachers but
there's a lot of
um factors to take into account one of
the factors is the energy costs that
schools are facing so you have to look
at what are the other costs that schools
are facing and so that's what that's
where there is room to talk with the
unions about what's happening what their
what they understand is the evidence to
submit to the pair of your body these
are the kind of discussions we want to
have behind closed doors I absolutely do
want there to be a well-rewarded
well-motivated tuition profession so
that we can see those standards we've
seen rise since 2010 in Reading in maths
in gcses uh in our schools we want that
to continue and it can't continue if we
don't have a properly rewarded a
teaching profession
and I want to talk to you a bit about
Matt Hancock
uh in the Daily Telegraph day lots of
his WhatsApp messages uh were made
available during the covid-19 pandemic
by the journalist Isabel Oak shorts
now I guess my main question about this
right is there was lots of stuff about
testing okay so there was stuff about
whether or not he went against the
advice of the chief medical officer
about testing in Care Homes there was a
message that he exchanged with George
Osborne who was then the editor of the
evening standard asking him to try and
help him meet his Target that he'd set
and you can't help thinking this is a
guy that it seems was more concerned
about hitting his own targets for
political gain rather than was the right
thing to do in the covert pandemic well
all this of course will come out in the
the covert inquiry but what I do know uh
speaking as a minister who was around at
the time is that we were dealing with a
very very serious health issue this is a
new virus which none of us had any
immune immunity to uh at that stage
there was no vaccine we didn't know
there could be a vaccine to a
coronavirus and so we had to take some
very serious decisions very rapidly we
had to take them in the education sphere
and that had to take them in the health
sphere but we did a lean on the advice
of the of people like Chris Whitty we
took very certainly from supposedly uh
Department of Education is concerned and
I'm absolutely sure the same in health
that we took advice and we and we you
know we abided by this it doesn't seem
right but that's I guess that's the
point though isn't it doesn't sound like
Matt Hancock was necessarily abiding by
the advice of the experts well you know
if everything I know about Matt he
that's exactly what he would be doing
but they'd all come out in the in the
covert inquiry and it'll be wrong to
preempt you know what is a very
important inquiry from which we will
learn as a government about how to
handle future pandemics like this which
inevitably will happen in the future
some might have questions about Matt
Hancock's judgment right um looking at
these WhatsApp messages around Care
Homes looking at his decision to go on
I'm a celebrity uh looking at um some of
his other decisions as well when he was
found to have broken the rules during
the covert pandemic that he himself set
and then subsequently resigned
and I guess the question some of our
viewers might be having is how on Earth
was this man at the top of politics for
all this time whose judgment and all
these things seems to be called under
question well the you know the what's
that message you're only getting one
part of the story from those what's that
message yet so I think it's wrong to to
judge maths and uh but just by that and
I guess it's a judgment question as well
that the fact that he gave his WhatsApp
messages to Isabell Lake shot in the
first place well he trusted a journalist
and you know I don't know what you would
say about that but
um look you know we have to wait for the
coven inquiry uh I work closely with
Matt Hancock and and the other ministers
in in the department for health and I
know they're well motivated people all
of them who relied on the the expert
advice from the medical profession from
Chris Whittier the chief scientist and
they've and I think if you look at what
happened during the covet crisis the way
we got the vaccine one of the first
countries to have the vaccine we it
saved millions of lives around the world
and I think you know the covert inquiry
where we'll look at all these now look
at all the WhatsApp messages that look
at all the internal submissions and
advice and decisions that were taken in
the formal way as they are in
departments and we'll then draw some
conclusions about mistakes that were
made I am sure there will be mistakes
made absolutely but they'll also look at
what we've got right and what we can
learn for the Future Okay
um just finally um I had a big deal on
brexit of course that's been presented
this week I just want to have a quick
look at something that Rishi sunak said
about the deal that Northern Ireland got
under I think you know what's coming
probably let's have a quick lesson
Northern Ireland is in the unbelievably
special position unique position in the
entire world European
privileged access not just to the UK
Home Market but also the European Union
single Market nobody else has that
no one
only you guys only here
and that is the prize
can you think of any other country that
previously had that incredibly
privileged position as well
well you mean when we were in the
European Union do you mean but there was
if that was access to both the single
market and the UK internal Market of
course but you know that was a decision
taken by the British people we live in a
democracy we have to deliver and we have
delivered uh the brexit was demanded you
know in our demo through our Democratic
referendum and what is great about the
deal that uh the Prime Minister has
secured is that we have a position where
we the Northern Ireland is absolutely
part of the union with Great Britain
that Goods can float through the to and
fro between Northern Ireland and Great
Britain and also uh we don't need a hard
border between north and south southern
island this is the unique position of
southern Ireland in any other uh border
with the European Union in the single
Market there would be a hard border
between the two elements and what we
have what what what uh the Prime
Minister has secured is continuation of
that open border while at the same time
ensuring that Northern Ireland is
absolutely firmly part of of the United
Kingdom but if it's so great that
Northern Ireland has got this access to
the single Market why why not the rest
of us why not Scotland Wales other
places that voted or Scotland that voted
to remain well the issue is the open
border that's that's the issue it's
about the Belfast agreement making sure
we don't have a Resurgence but no my my
question is if access to the single
Market is so great why doesn't Russia's
CNAC negotiate that for the rest of us
because we don't want to rejoin uh the
European Union that's the decision that
the British people took in 2016 and I
think it would be wrong to undo that
decision what we've got to do is make
brexit work and if you you see
speculation in the newspaper now about
the trans-pacific partnership there's
there's a whole raft of opportunities
for the United Kingdom and uh not you
know not trading with the European Union
as it is now uh uh we need to you know
we need to make sure that we are using
that market for the future and have a
proper trading agreement with the
European Union but also with the rest of
the world and I'm very excited about
life outside of the European Union okay
thank you very much
well we'll get Labor's take on all of
that a bit later on but first we can
speak to our Deputy political editor Sam
coats Matt Hancock that's what
everyone's been talking about today uh
isn't it
um how I mean what is going on what's
going on these messages suddenly in the
telegraph because he handed them over to
uh is by Lake Shore it's just
extraordinary
so there was something like two million
words in total in the WhatsApp messages
from Matt Hancock that he handed over to
a journalist for the purposes of writing
a ghost writing his Memoir in other
words to make money and now she's done
the dirty on them or published them in
the public interest you know your plenty
money and takes your choices The
Narrative and they've all gone across
six pages of the telegraph today but
there'll be more at 11 30 tonight stay
tuned to Sky News maybe by the telegraph
too uh and tomorrow and the next day and
this is the private messages of the man
at the center of uh kovid at the most
sensitive time in the state's recent
history and it's his communication with
a whole bunch of senior officials
advisors uh external experts um the
Prime Minister I mean there are messages
from Boris Johnson
um with Boris Johnson going I'm going
crackers and I'm at Hancock replying
don't go crackers prime minister and and
as well as just the sort of cheer naked
um uh kind of raw intensity of reading
these communications from one of the
most stressful moments in in in in
recent British political history I think
you learn a couple of things first of
all it's governed by WhatsApp secondly
there is a sort of uh informality to it
that's you know on really important
issues thirdly
there is some signs that you can't quite
trust everything he's saying you know
he's he's um Matt Hancock is and
particularly when it comes to achieving
that Infamous testing Target uh you know
leave as a pool that means I don't quite
think uh it was achieved in the way that
they claimed uh and just I I think it
will be poured over for some time
extraordinary as you say government by
WhatsApp in itself just incredible to
see uh laid there more from Sam uh later
you are watching the take we're live at
Westminster got lots more uh coming up
next we're talking to the chair of the
labor party and these Dodds
[Music]
thank you
I'm Katie Spencer and I'm Sky news's
arts and entertainment correspondent
Maverick here on the red carpet I'm so
excited Katie Spencer Sky News in London
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
they have breached the road there is a
lot of protesting fired all around us
[Music]
I am
it is
and now they're going to be arrested we
aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is here that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
but today it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of Northeast Delhi where there's been
clashes
I'm never Lazarus and I'm Skye's
reporter based in Delhi
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back we are in Westminster
for the take let's get Labor's view now
a little bit earlier I spoke to the
party's chair annalize Dodds
and first of all I just want to get your
reaction to the WhatsApp messages of
Matt Hancock leaked in the telegraph
today what was your kind of main
reaction to that
well I remember as I'm sure viewers will
remember when the government said that
they were putting a protective ring
around Care Homes well these messages
show that the government knew that the
alarm was going off up and down the
country they knew there was a problem
and yet ministers didn't act and I think
for many people who obviously had loved
ones who died during that period you
know it was an awful tough time for our
country I think this will be bringing
all of that up really what those people
deserve now from government is they
deserve that covert inquiry to get on
and to speed up you know other countries
from France to Brazil have been far
quicker with their processes than we've
been in our country you know we haven't
had a single government Minister up in
front of that inquiry yet that's just
not good enough
um do you think
um I mean Matt Hancock says that look
it's only a partial part of the exchange
that's been published here and he says
look we should wait for the covert
inquiry team maybe you and him the same
page there but is there a data
protection issue from my Hancock side as
well I mean he's a person who handed all
these messages over right
I think there are many questions about
Matt Hancock's conduct to be completely
honest in a variety of directions what
I'm really concerned about is that we're
not seeing the conservative government
actually focused on learning the lessons
from that period so what is the number
one lesson then you think well I think
there are many lessons above all
actually listening to what people were
seeing during that period you know I
remember a care home manager it was
almost in tears with me on the phone
during that period of course we're all
sat in our houses back then you know
stuck in our homes I was speaking to him
on the phone and he was saying I just
can't access the test that I need and
I'm sure that people have been sent back
here who are infectious remember the day
very very well government ministers were
saying that there wasn't a problem there
so we need to learn those lessons that's
why we need that inquiry to speed up
okay well we're going to get that
inquiry and I'm sure lots of these
questions will be reflected on then the
other thing that I wanted to ask you
about and the Prime Minister gave that a
speech in here in Northern Ireland where
he was talking about the Northern
Ireland being in the unique position
where they had the benefits of being in
the UK internal Market with access to
the single Market as well does this mean
that the prime minister's now more in
favor of single Market access for the UK
than the leader of the opposition
well Labor's been very clear we won't
rejoin the single Market we won't rejoin
the Customs Union why not well because
we're determined instead to make the
Practical changes that could actually
make that brexit deal work for our
country okay so what are those practical
changes then you think so for example
why is it the case that a country like
New Zealand hundreds and hundreds of
miles away from us has a Veterinary
agreement with the EU and yet the UK
doesn't have a Veterinary agreement you
know that's something that would strip
off loads of red tape that's tying up UK
food exporters at the moment simple
change again we've said that we should
have a security pact with the EU to keep
our country safe these are measures we
could put in place quickly that are in
our country's interests and I guess what
some people say is that look you can do
all these individual things on
Veterinary agreements or sausages or
whatever it is surely the simplest thing
would be try and negotiate access to the
single market then it's just one deal
isn't it and then that's done well I
don't agree with that and I have to say
I've talked with many businesses about
this what they want to see are those
pragmatic Speedy changes getting rid of
the additional bureaucracy that the
conservatives have put in their way
actually and making sure that they can
export and import so they can provide
the extra jobs and growth that our
country desperately needs is there
something I guess so like people
listening to to you and other people
within the labor party who campaigned
four remain for Maine was the right
thing to do and thinking look if you
were so in favor of the single market
then why are you not in favor of the
single market now what's changed other
than the fact you're just following a
public opinion well actually I believe
in democracy and yes you're right that I
did campaign for remain but ultimately
that wasn't the result delivered by the
referendum and actually looking at the
situation now what I'm really concerned
about is for example the small
manufacturing Market they did it just
said to be in or out of the European
Union it wasn't referendum on whether we
should be part of the single Market or
Customs Union
but actually Libra's been clear we're
not going to be seeking that membership
of the single market and of the Customs
Union we believe that we can make
changes quickly that are going to be
critical for our economy that's what
we're focused on and I want to talk to
you a bit about a policy that you have
now to try to help people with menopause
at work I know it's one of these things
isn't it where it kind of feels like
with the menopause it's something we
just haven't talked about enough as a
society right and I thought that as a
woman it's something that you know
people just don't talk about you know
whether it's to other people in their
family or in politics or whatever it is
what what do you want to try and change
well you know I couldn't agree with you
more about people not talking about it
and that has often applied in the
workplace as well and I've spoken with
many women who have been experiencing
symptoms finding it difficult to manage
those symptoms at the same time as
working knowing that if some changes
were made at work that could really help
them but actually they're not able to
talk with their manager they feel
because they think their manager just
won't understand and actually what labor
set out with are menopause action plan
policy is a really simple and effective
way of getting companies to focus on
what would support those women it's
really important for a business in our
economy because some research suggests
that about one in ten women experiencing
those symptoms have actually dropped out
of their job because they couldn't
combine work with those things the idea
is that companies I think it's with 250
employers employees or more have to
report what they're doing to try and
help people with the menopauser at work
why do you think it that we have been
saying reticent to talk about the
menopausal really
and of course 51 of the population will
go through it at some point I mean I
have to say if you think generally about
that age group of women you're 45 to 55
you know we tend not to talk a lot about
uh what we're experiencing we just get
on with it a lot of the time and But
ultimately you know those women they're
in the prime of their lives they're
often the most experienced employees in
the workplace along with their meal
counterparts at the same age they do
need to be supported for their sake but
for the sake of our economy as well uh
just finally and Sky users Joe Pike has
discovered that Sue gray is being
considered to be the next chief staff
for care Starman now she of course was
the woman who sat in judgment on Boris
Johnson
that a woman of this important role
presiding over the fates of the
conservative prime minister should now
be considered to work for the labor
party well I'm not going to comment on
any HR matter what I would say is that
we're finding and certainly I see as
labor party chair you know very many
people from a whole range of different
walks of life who are now wanting to
connect with the labor party you know
you understand what I'm getting at from
that question there right whether it
people might think that it's actually
appropriate I guess for somebody who had
this role where she's in Judgment of a
conservative prime minister should now
be Chief of Staff potentially for a
labor politician as I said I'm not going
to comment on an HR matter but what I
would say as I just mentioned is there's
any every single day well but every
single day I'm getting emails from
people who've had a whole variety of
experience you know people who served
previously in government actually quite
often former conservative who are
contacting me saying that they want to
support labor that they want to make
sure that we win the next general
election say between someone who might
have voted conservative to the past and
Sue gray yeah the Sue gray report this
was a big deal
well I have to say that I find a whole
variety of people with a variety of
backgrounds who want to support labor
now and that is the difference you know
it's labor that is setting out that
hopeful future the way we're going to
get there you know care couldn't have
been clearer with that with his missions
that he set out just a few days ago they
can see that change can come and it's
coming from labor okay I'll leave it
there thank you
and they still say well let's hear from
the guy who broke that story shall we uh
Jay Pike our political uh correspondent
Sue gray I was going to raise a couple
of eyebrows if it does go ahead it
already is within a government there are
a ton of ethical questions here
potentially in senior people within
government I've been speaking to tonight
seem pretty perplexed by this because of
course Sue gray who you can see here did
pass judgment on the behavior of lots of
conservative politicians not just Boris
Johnson around a party gate but Damien
green around some claims around
pornography he left the cabinet Andrew
Mitchell Around The plebgate Saga he
left uh cabinet and even though she may
be able to approach this as a balanced
civil servant the prospect of her moving
into a very political role I think is
troubling uh for some now Sue gray
hasn't commented on the story won't
comment labor saying the process is
ongoing nobody has been offered a job
the biggest sort of recent comparison I
suppose although it's not that recent is
Jonathan Powell who Tony Blair appointed
as Chief of Staff in opposition then
became the first Chief of Staff in
Street in 1997 his background was in the
Civil Service but as a diplomat the
difference here Sophie is that Sue gray
was in charge of ethics and propriety
for many years although as annalize is
pointing out there some within labor are
arguing tonight this shows we're
preparing for government and potentially
if she does get off of the job
attracting senior Talent yeah really
interesting stuff she's so synonymous
with that part of gate stuff isn't she
thanks very much indeed good to have you
on the program this evening
we're live in Westminster for you you're
watching the take up next we're going to
be having a closer look at today's pmq
you can have more Jay Pike
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back live to Westminster you are
watching the take time for us now to
take a close look at primus's questions
it was a packed Commons as ever at
lunchtime with lots on the agenda from
the cost of living to Northern Ireland
plus those Revelations about Mount
Hancock well our political correspondent
Joe Pike has been looking at the
highlights this is pmqs unwrapped
at last week's pmqs kirst armor tried to
ferment back bench Tory division on
Northern Ireland but after a largely
positive response to Rishi sunak's new
deal with the EU that topic now might
prove fruitless so instead the labor
leader hedged his Bets with a more
scattergun approach
energy bills are going to go up by 900
pounds in April house building is going
to fall to its lowest level in 75 years
if he scrapped his non-dom status he
could start to fund better child care
and the prime minister's tactic was to
respond by lambasting Labor's policies
stop making inflationary unfunded
spending commitments stand up to the
vested interest in the unions and back
our minimum service level
it's the same old labor party always
running out of other people's money
that final Barb was a line Margaret
Thatcher used in 1976 now Richard sunak
also managed to Pivot from answering a
question on housing to attacking Labor's
position on energy it is an absurd
policy but it didn't escape the
attention of a Commons Club he seemed to
point this out to the speaker who then
said this
because of the noise I don't think the
prime minister's hearing the questions
because I do think it was on host
building Pierce
after more than 100 000 of Matt
Hancock's WhatsApp messages from his
time as health secretary were leaked to
a newspaper the labor leader also asked
when we'll find out the truth about the
government's pandemic response
the covered inquiry has already cost the
taxpayer 85 million pounds and hasn't
heard from a single government Minister
yet he has mentioned it one or two times
before that he was a lawyer in a
previous life that there is a proper
process to these things it is an
independent inquiry
and one kirst armor questioned about the
economy unexpectedly mentioned the 1980s
TV comedy drama our feeders aimed pet
about British Builders leaving the UK to
work in Germany if the tour is limped on
in government we're going to see a
generation of young people learning to
say I'll be the same pet in Polish
aren't we
the smps Westminster leader didn't seem
convinced
later Stephen Flynn returned to his
favorite topic of brexit allowing him to
attack both of the smps Scottish Rivals
Mr Speaker let's be clear what the Prime
Minister said yesterday was the EU
single Market access will be a good
thing for business now of course that's
in contrast the leader of the labor
party who said in December the EU single
Market access would not boost economic
growth does it hurt the prime minister
to know that the labor party believe in
brexit more than he does yeah the
important thing to note is to avoid a
land border on the island of Ireland
between North and South
elsewhere there were questions about a
refugee choir singing at the king's
coronation if it turns out that any of
the refugees taking part in that choir
have arrived here on small boats or from
a safe Third Country should they be
deported to Rwanda before or after they
signed for the king and a mention of one
of our own investigations
prime minister may be aware of Sky
news's investigation and report today on
the over-the-counter sales of nitrous
oxide or laughing gas to children and
young teenagers one alarming aspect is
the change in the size of canisters from
8 grams to 620 grams the Prime Minister
responded to that by saying he was
concerned that a review is underway the
government he said had asked for it to
be accelerated and he will then consider
next steps
Jay Pike there at talking three pmqs you
probably noticed there he finished by
talking about the question of Rosie
Duffield the labor MP for uh Canterbury
who was asking about that Sky News
investigation into laughing gas and I'm
glad to say that Rosie joins us on the
program now to talk a little bit more
about why she asked the question what
she made of the response from the PM so
just talk us through a bit more why did
you decide to ask that
um I had an adjournment debate a couple
of years ago probably about 18 months
ago because parents of my constituency
were telling me that those little
canisters were all over our beach I
noticed them when I was walking the dog
he was kind of trying to get one in his
mouth and I didn't really know what they
were I talked to my children about it
and some people in local schools and I
didn't realize how easily available this
noxious gas was to children just over
the counter exactly how your report
found yeah and in this report just in
case you haven't seen the full report
um it's basically Sky News investigates
going in in to buy these canisters for
recreational use and effectively and
sold them with balloons and very easily
and by shopkeepers I think you're right
aren't you I mean they're everywhere you
know I noticed them you know sometimes
on the side of the road or the music
festivals yeah everywhere and they used
to be sold in these eight gram tiny
little canisters but your reporters have
found that more often they're now sold
in these 620 gram containers and if
children would take you know young
people who haven't developed properly
yet are taking them in those quantities
they can lead to some serious brain and
spinal problems and you know children
aren't being warned about that I don't
think what do you think needs to happen
because mind of something is the laws
that Sanders it's not illegal to
actually no to use this no of course not
and I don't think we should be
penalizing children or unions I think
you had to report earlier with Mark
Garnier who's had some experiences with
his constituents I don't think anyone
wants the children to be prosecuted but
those people who knowingly sell to
children who are way under 18. it's
pretty obvious or at least is my D I
don't think they should get away with
just being able to do that what did you
make of the PM's response I know that
they're reviewing things and they're
talking to the body that looks at these
things and hopefully they're going to
listen to some constituents that you
know we're talking about as MPS and
really take action and the other thing
that's quite interesting because minor
something is is the same thing that you
use in labor right gas and air yeah the
same thing which I didn't even you know
it's kind of weird to kind of Link those
two things that's different which is
great I mean that feeling oh yeah sort
of slightly out of it but you know you
can imagine all kinds of things
happening to you if you're not really in
control of your body and as adults we
can make those decisions but children as
young as 12 and 13 really shouldn't be
anywhere near this stuff and also it's
interesting isn't it because I guess
with you know because I I've used you
know get gas and air before through um
labor and it's quite
yeah I mean if you have too much you
remember that feeling where you go
really light-headed If you're sort of
trying to you know your brain's
developing your body's developing you're
not kind of able to make that decision
and know what it's doing to you I don't
think yeah exactly
um thanks very much for being on the uh
program uh today Rosie really good to
have you on as always talk about such an
important discussion as well you're
watching uh the take we're live in
Westminster for you up next we're gonna
be rounding up everything we've heard
with pancakes
foreign
[Music]
Spencer and I'm Sky news's arts and
entertainment correspondent Maverick
here on the red carpet I'm so excited
Katie Spencer Sky News in London
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
there is a lot of protests being fired
all around us
[Music]
it is
and now they're going to be arrested we
aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is here that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
today it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of Northeast Delhi where there's been
clashes
I'm Neville Lazarus and I'm Skye's
reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
foreign
welcome back hello to Westminster you're
watching the take we've had lots of
takes this evening we have a bit of post
uh match Roundup with our Deputy
political editors I'm Kate is here again
we've let you sit on the chairs so
rather than having to stand by the wall
we're having a nice kind of coffee table
at moment here and it feels actually
doesn't it like it's been a massive week
when it comes to brexit let's be honest
quite a few of our viewers will probably
be thinking brexit again please don't
talk about that anymore we've heard
enough about it over the last few years
but what's your sort of take on why is
actually significant I think it's
massive I think it's absolutely massive
and you don't need to get into the
detail you don't need to pay any
attention to the political Rouse uh to
appreciate why it's massive and it's and
it's for this reason
for the last seven years conservative
successive conservative Prime Ministers
and conservative-led governments have
basically approached our closest
neighbors and the and the whole uh
subject of diplomacy as one in which we
have two pick fights we continually
picked fights with the European Union we
even started picking fights with the US
when they sided with the European Union
we have been pugnacious not particularly
Pleasant we've been the Bad Boys uh uh
on uh to some degree on the Diplomatic
scene uh unusually for a country that's
normally uh uh taken a much more nuanced
approach to uh world affairs and what
Rishi sinak has done is draw a line onto
that in quite a big way so no longer are
we threatening to unilaterally rip-up
treaties that we have signed but instead
we have relationship that has sent a
signal that he is now going to do things
by negotiation and that is such a big
change so two MPS that have had seven
years of defending the pugnacious
approach are now having to defend
actually doing it as it were the way
that we to do it the the slightly calmer
uh more sensible way and that just
approach I suspect which is soon at
hopes will unlock a lot more gains in
other areas like Horizon we saw but uh
small boats with a summit with the
present macron next week on Friday uh I
think with Joe Biden coming over for the
25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement so Britain is about to try and
be positioned by rishis you know because
being back on the world stage as a
grown-up and that's just so different
from the way that Theresa May Boris
Johnson and particularly Liz truss he
was quite understanding quite unpleasant
to Joe Biden behind the scenes uh did it
for um many many years it's so
interesting isn't it I have to admit I
was kind of skeptical thinking why are
they doing this on brexit like at the
time when the DP with madving off you
know you were talking to you're a
skeptic so we're really going for Rishi
c-neck maybe actually it's going to be
common Waters than we thought it may
just be the best thing that Richard
zinac has done so far as prime minister
I think that people underestimated this
agreement they underestimated the
political impact of deal and they
underestimated his ability to sell it
but now he's actually got it over the
line he has at least it looks like got
one concrete achievement it's really
interesting Sam always get to talk
thanks very much for being on the take
this evening for you well that is it for
the take we'll be back next uh Wednesday
at 9 00 PM next up it's Sky News at 10
I'll be back of course at Sunday morning
as well lots to talk about as always
with those School strikes tomorrow
thanks very much for watching this
evening
foreign
[Music]